bitcoins meteoric rise is attracting a
ton of attention but is it ready for the
mainstream JPMorgan Chase CEO Jamie
Dimon recently called Bitcoin a fraud
and said that cryptocurrency prices are
in a bubble that will eventually burst
many investors have stayed on the
sidelines as cryptocurrencies are seen
as too volatile and don't have the
safeguards that most financial assets do
a number of hedge funds however are
investing in cryptocurrencies and
Goldman Sachs is reportedly exploring
how it could help clients trade digital
tokens other companies are stepping up
efforts to bring cryptocurrency to the
mainstream opening regulated exchanges
creating futures contracts and
attempting to list exchange-traded funds
the recent surge in cryptocurrency
prices has coincided with a flood of
interest about the blockchain technology
behind Bitcoin which uses a
decentralized and public ledger of
transactions that can't be manipulated
IBM Microsoft and Toyota have all
invested in blockchain and are looking
at potential applications ranging from
food safety to driverless cars so what
is preventing even more widespread
adoption regulation or the lack thereof
in July 2017 the SEC announced that
federal securities law may apply to some
cryptocurrencies without providing
concrete guidelines to determine which
ones meanwhile China has outright banned
icos or initial coin offerings along
with the exchanges where coins are
traded guidelines for individuals that
mine and trade cryptocurrencies also
vary wildly with countries like
Venezuela going as far as putting miners
in jail so what's next in the year ahead
the cryptocurrency community is eager
for clarity from regulators on icos
treating mining
and taxes as that happens more investors
and end-users could dip their toes in
the water many have compared the current
state of blockchain to the early days of
the internet a digital Wild West teaming
with opportunity and just like the
Internet there will likely be winners
and losers
you